ese capítulo especial para Albania tiene
que ver con que la mayoría de los
inmigrantes ilegales son de esa
nacionalidad en este año se han
registrado
45.000 que han llegado a través del
Canal de la Mancha y de estos 13.000 son
de esa nacionalidad como lo mencionas
habrá aumento de personal para acelerar
la solicitudes de asilo en el Reino
Unido también para acelerar los trámites
Que no se les ha dado respuesta y según
de Times más de 150.000 personas están
esperando una respuesta sobre el asilo
de estas Diez mil personas están
alojadas en hoteles que está pagando el
gobierno por ello estas personas serán
movidas a parques de vacaciones bases
militares residencias estudiantiles
abandonadas para que el gobierno no
tenga que seguir pagando casi seis
millones de libras esterlinas diarias
por estos alojamientos también se creará
una unidad especial para evitar la
llegada masiva de estos pequeños barcos
a través del Canal de la Mancha y
también más recursos para las
autoridades para evitar que más bandas
criminales sigan trayendo migrantes
ilegales a través del Canal que todos
los días arriesgan sus vidas